there are two Ravens that sit on his
shoulders and whisper the news they see
and hear into his ear
they're called Hugin and muninn he sends
them out in the morning to fly around
the whole world and by breakfast they
are back again he finds out many new
things and this is why he is called
Raven God throughout the years
Odin has been depicted as the wise all
father ever vigilant and ever knowin a
source of this vast knowledge and
perception displayed by Odin can be
linked to the connection with his two
raven companions who jinn and muninn and
the name hogan derives from old norse
and means thought whereas Moonen can be
roughly translated to mind or memory
concepts that are shown to be highly
valued by Odin Odin's association with
the Ravens goes as far back as a sixth
century AD hundreds of years before the
Viking Age in the 8th century even in
these times Odin was quite often
depicted as being accompanied by one or
more Ravens it was quite common for
stories and early poetry of the Viking
Age to refer to Odin as the Raven got
the Raven tempter and even the priests
of Ravens sacrifice the sacrifice
referred to that a fool and warriors in
battle it was believed that Odin decided
who lived in battle and who was
sacrificed to the Ravens and the other
carry and birds would feast on their
remains slain someone in battle was also
considered to be given the Raven a gift
sometimes warriors are even referred to
as feeders of the Raven the gift of a
slain warrior in battle was also seen as
a gift to Odin as he was the ruler of
the dead in Valhalla it became pretty
common practice to attempt to appease
Odin and his Ravens before battle with
the sacrifice of an effigy in the form
of your enemy
every morning at the crack of dawn Odin
would send huqin and muninn across the
Norse world they would return by supper
where they would purchase on his
shoulders and inform him of what they
had seen and heard we can see the
connection between Odin and his ravens
in the poetic edda grimness mall where
Odin says Huyen and muninn fly over all
the world I worry for Hugin that he
might not return but I worry more for
Moonen we can look at this as an example
that Odin cares for his companions but
it could also be said that the birds are
an extension of Odin himself there are
some scholars who make the case that
huginn and muninn are embodiments of
Odin's luck in traditional Norse culture
the spirit can be broken down into many
parts and can be separated Odin's Locke
is believed to be the part that he sent
out on errands and thus we have huginn
and muninn as physical embodiments there
are no dissonant features that make
Huyen and muninn stand out they appear
as regular run-of-the-mill ravens large
haunting birds with sharp beaks beady
eyes and thick black feathers you could
argue that Hugin and muninn having their
own unique appearance would impede their
daily tasks
appearing as regular Ravens meant that
they could travel undetected gathering
only the information they needed and
aroused no suspicion if this wasn't the
case then they could easily be
identified and it's likely that they
would be targeted by the enemies of Odin
and those seeking knowledge despite
appearing as ordinary Birds the two were
quite far from that and they possess
some quite interest in abilities being
able to fly across the entire North
world in a day would mean that they
would have to travel at speeds greater
than any ordinary bird was capable of
they were also able to understand and
speak the language of men it sounds very
much like Hugin and muninn were merely
Odin spies but they were much more than
just that Ravens are generally
considered as intelligent birds but
these two were capable of making complex
observations and served as advisors they
would often follow Odin into battle
scouting ahead and advising the God on
how he should approach the opposing
forces
Huyen and muninn one doubtedly two of
odin's most important companions and it
was no coincidence that they were
depicted as Ravens the connection of the
Ravens in the Norse people is one that
stems quite far back the early Norse
people were hunters and recognized in a
pattern it was common for Ravens to
follow the trail of hunters for several
days waitin to feed and what remained of
the hunt
sometimes these roles were even reversed
with the hunters following the Ravens as
they circled the skies in search for a
meal the bond between man and animal was
created when the Norse people embarked
on sea voyages they took Ravens with
them in cages the Ravens would be
released and they would guide the birds
to land upon arriving in these
unfamiliar lands people would follow the
Ravens who led them towards food the
Ravens played quite an integral role in
the everyday lives of the Norse people
and they were even revered by many it's
no real surprise that Hugin and muninn
also played an integral role in Norse
mythology the Ravens would be remembered
forever as they took their place perched
upon the shoulders of the all-father
Odin I hope you guys enjoyed today's
video if you did then let me know what
you thought in the comments below I am
pretty excited about the next couple
weeks because I have quite a few videos
that I think you guys will really enjoy
and I can't wait to start recording them
the first patron votive video will also
be out in the next couple of days so
stay tuned for all of that but as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained